logan have you thought about the
possibility that your children are
actually scared of you oh off I'm
dr. Ali Mattu cognitive behavioral
therapist and I'm here today in
collaboration with HBO to offer my take
on themes of mental health in their
shows today we're going to unpack
attachment what it is and how it can
have a tremendous impact on our lives by
looking at the show succession can you
give us a minute please
attachment is the basic unit of a
relationship between a parent and a
child you me it's what happens
when one person is struggling and how
they get support from another person
three years ago we were still in the
nuthouse rehab we have a father who is
testing his son making his son more
angry invalidating his feelings do you
want to hit me is that it
go long dad come on what are you doing
are you gonna cry good
attachment heals the pain bad attachment
makes the emotions worse roman memorial
good parent listens to their kid bad
parent pushes her kid away by not taking
their feelings seriously you're nothing
all know your role you're a
coward what's really important about
attachment is learning how to validate
other people's emotions what are you
waiting for the kiss
off instead of saying toughen up or
don't be a baby if your kid is upset
talk to them about how it's okay to be
sad you've people difficult times
validation helps people calm their
emotions so that they can then tackle
life's problems it's never too late to
steer relationships in a positive
direction and open up line
of communication that's my take for the
day
I'm dr. Matta
[Music]
you